good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's a not so
theoretical question
when is it okay to pay off female
accusers
nbc news has had no problem doing it
over the years on behalf of
grabby tv anchors but now that donald
trump
is accused of doing it nbc tells us
that's a felony
how exactly does that work we'll explain
just ahead
but first even by the high standards of
2018 it was a bizarro day here in
washington the president
invited democratic leaders chuck schumer
and nancy pelosi into the oval office
turned on the cameras and informed them
he was ready to shut down the federal
government in order to get a border wall
here's what happened next one thing i
think we can agree on is we shouldn't
shut
down the government over a dispute and
you want to shut it down you keep
talking about it the last time chuck you
shut it down no no no and then you
opened
any time very quickly i don't want to do
what you did 20 times you have called
for i will shut down the government if i
don't get my wall
none of us if you want to know something
you've said okay you want to put that in
you said it
i'll take it okay good you know what
i'll say yes
if we don't get what we want one way or
the other whether it's through you
through a military through anything you
want to call i will shut down the
government okay absolutely enough
and i am proud and i disagree i am proud
to shut down the government
for border security chuck because the
people of this country
don't want criminals and people that
have lots of problems and drugs pouring
into our country so
i will take the mantle i will be the one
to shut it down i'm not going to blame
you for it
the last time you shut it down it didn't
work i will take the mantle of shutting
down
if body language is any indication chuck
schumer has never hated
anything in his whole life more than he
hated that moment you just saw
weirdly in washington there's always a
scramble to blame the other side
for government shutdowns that's not what
happened today as you just heard the
president said he would be proud to
take responsibility for the government
shutting down because a wall
is too important we need border security
the wall is a part of border security
you can't have very good border security
without the world now
that is a political promise border
security is a way to effectively
honor our response and the experts say
you can do border security without a
wall which is wasteful and doesn't solve
the problem
now by this point in the exchange not a
single person watching at home was
tempted to change the channel it was
just too compelling
the president himself appeared to be
enjoying it
pelosi was not enjoying it she
complained that the world was watching
their argument in real time but the
president would not relent
we came in here in good faith uh and and
we're entering into uh this kind of a
discussion
in the public view but it's not bad
nancy no no
you know nancy's in a situation where
it's not
easy for her to talk right now and i
understand that and i fully understand
that
we're going to have a good discussion
and we're going to see what happens
but we have to have border security
please don't characterize
the strength that i bring to this
meeting as the leader
of the house democrats who just won a
big victory elections have consequences
mr president
it was an amazing moment the president
is at his best when he's fighting for
the interests of the people who voted
for him and for the principles that he
ran on
but tweeting is not making policy and
threatening a shutdown is not the same
as shutting down the government or as
getting a wall built
the president has actually made that
threat before in march he signed a
spending bill with no wall funding but
said he would never sign a bill like
that again
and then in july he tweeted this quote i
would be willing to shut down government
if the democrats should not give us the
votes for border security
which includes a wall but a september
budget showdown came and went with no
shutdown and no wall this
december 2018 is the president's final
chance to get a border wall the wall was
central
to his campaign in 2016 that will never
happen while democrats control a chamber
of commerce
we'll see what happens in the meantime
richard goodstein joins us tonight he's
an attorney who advise both bill and
hillary clinton
and we're happy to have him so i'm a
little bit just to get to the theatrics
of it were amazing we don't know whether
pelosi and schumer knew there were going
to be cameras there when all of that
will become clear in the coming days but
what is clear is that democrats
adamantly oppose a wall
but they're for offense so what's the
difference
well again the signature promise was
we're going to build a wall and mexico
is going to pay for it we just had a
nafta deal signed
which was his opportunity to get mexico
to pay and he didn't
so can we at least suspend any belief
that
he's going to make good on that part of
the problem can we agree on that i think
the rest of us
are interested not just in the rhetoric
but like we have 22 million people here
illegally
that's a disaster everyone agrees the
the latest estimate is 22 we have tens
of millions of people here legally
and our borders are not secure democrats
have said we're for offense
but we're against a wall because as
pelosi told us last week a wall is
immoral
why what is the difference between a
fence and a wall why is offense okay but
a wall is not
well i think the democrats view and
again i'll quote john kelly in this
confirmation hearing
when he was up for uh homeland security
a physical barrier in and of itself
does not do the job we don't want to
keep playing goal-line defense against
people trying to come in from another
country
so the ant and and again can we agree
when the president says
we're starting we build a wall that's
nonsense we had those prototypes
still sitting in the desert for months
and months and months and he was
supposed to pick one and he hasn't but i
think you can always agree that he's
well we can agree with what i've said a
million times on the show which is he
promised to build a wall and we should
build one now
and what he's asking for now and it's
late i agree with you but he's asking
for the money to pay for the wall that
he promised
and that people want people voted for
him for that 64 million people
so most people voted against him but
okay okay but why are democrats again i
just don't understand what the
opposition
is so it's wasteful okay this is a party
that supports head start after 55 years
of failed results so like waste is not a
real issue that's a lie
why do they support a fence but not a
wall i'm honestly
being a sort of simple person like
explain it to me so again when the when
there was a bill that passed the senate
back in 2013 with votes from pinkos like
orrin hatch and lindsey graham and marco
rubio
for comprehensive immigration reform it
included
beefing up border security it didn't
claw for a wall because as chuck schumer
said the experts believe that
the wall like israel has wouldn't be
effective here for a variety of reasons
so we could spend the whole segment
effective in israel
of course it has is it immoral no i
think it's been but why is it immoral
well because i think that the people
coming into israel there
are blowing people up in a way that the
immigrants here
are helping pick our food that's the
difference oh i mean some are picking
our food some are committing crimes but
the point is
israel built its wall because it wanted
to know who was coming over from the
territories
because it's it's it it's it's country
right right
this is our country so it's not immoral
when they do it but it is immoral when
we do it
well offense is okay but a wall is not
okay i mean i'm sincere
i don't think nancy pelosi said that the
wall it's what's important
three times what's immoral is spending
money on something you know that's not
going to work
and it's at the experts why are we
funding start john
no it hasn't not one year john kelly was
up for the department of homeland
security
secretary and he said the wall was
really not going to be built from sea to
shining sea
here's the point it doesn't whatever
we're doing does not work
and you know as well as i that the fear
with the wall is that it will work and
that will prevent
voters from coming over from latin
america to bolster the
fortunes of a party that actual
americans don't really like that much
which is the democratic party
so that's a caricature i know it's i'd
like to think that what's the real
answer
well it's not that what's the answer
because even that even the bill that the
democrats passed that would have passed
the house incidentally
and had 15 republican votes in the
senate
called for a very protracted period of
time before people who were already here
would get citizenship enabling them like
normal people were like look we don't
have control of our borders
a wall is not the whole answer donald
trump bragged about the fact today with
schumer and pelosi
about all these people being stopped i
mean he has to get his record straight
has it worked or is it not here today he
can't even be consistent he's here to
defend the country
not a politician illegal immigration is
actually
spiking right now there are lots of
reasons for that
but the fact remains that it's true and
it's bad for our country
we've never tried a wall a lot of
republicans are against the wall because
they're for illegal immigration
because their donors are for it because
it's cheap labor i get it it's not a
partisan question
i just want to know what the argument
against a wall is all the things we
spend money on
like why not try the wall and like no
that's immoral
why yeah well again i'm not saying it's
immoral i'm saying it's impractical and
i'm not the expert nor are you
but the people who are say it's
impractical that there are ways
well uh e-verification getting employers
not to hire people
who are here illegal right that would be
effective but democrats are opposed to
universal e-verify
that was in the bill that got every
single democratic vote there's no
universal democrat support for that
because their donors
make money from undercutting american
wages with
foreigners if they were i mean come on
well it was in the bill that passed with
every democrat vote in the senate in
2013 and would have passed the house
so you think pelosi's for universally
verified we're going to punish employers
if they hire illegals she's for that no
she's against it actually i don't think
that's true i think i think
pelosi has said from the start back then
if you bring up that
bill that passed the senate they're all
against it because
but like can you see the frustration
where we fund
other countries border walls and call
them virtuous
but americans are like we want to
protect our own country shut up racist
you're immoral don't you see the problem
yeah that would be a problem if it was
true what's true
is that we the democrats want to beef up
security along the border this notion of
it being open borders and democrats want
people to come in
that's a myth that's that's i know that
place to the base it happens just not to
be true
how did we get tens of millions of
illegals here that the democrats are
protecting and telling us we can never
deport like how how did that happen was
there for illegal immigration
duh well we're not saying actually obama
was criticized by the hispanic community
for deporting so many there's no
history there's no community of people
like i mean
there's a hispanic community there are
hispanic people who voted for trump
got all kinds of different views just
because people are of one ethnicity
doesn't mean they all have the same
views
do you know what i mean of course and
that's true on every issue yes it is but
i'm saying is that obama
uh deported millions of people so this
notion that democrats are unwilling to
deport
this that happens not to square with the
facts as well we still have all these
people here and i
i see nancy pelosi telling me i'm
immoral for wanting to fix it and it's
absolutely yeah i think that uh give her
a chance to get a bill passed in the
house
we'll see if the second mr mcconnell
takes it up good well yeah i hope you'll
come back
with us richardson thank you of course
google's ceo
came to capitol hill today congress
asked him a lot of questions did he
answer
any of them one of the republicans who
did the questioning joins us
next